growing up on the Savannah this Cal will
face many
dangers but a battle of this bit is
incredibly
rare two evenly matched testosterone
fueled
Bulls no place for a
baby
one day the Cal may have to fight like
this but there are far more imminent
threats a third of all Cals don't make
make it through their first
[Music]
year like all animals here his fate
depends on the grass growing under his
[Music]
feet
grasslands cover a quarter of the land
on the
planet they support the largest
animals and the biggest herds to walk
the
earth life on these Great Plains may
look easy but don't be
fooled when conditions turn they can
become some of the most volatile
Landscapes on our
[Music]
planet a Relentless cycle of
flood
famine
freeze and
Fire And as our climate becomes more
unpredictable it takes the animals of
the grasslands to hell and
back
a deepest wind win on North America's
Great
Plains 40
below and record
snowfall bison dig deeper for
diminishing
returns dead grass with the
nutrition of cardboard
23 of the stuff every day still isn't
enough they're
starving the calves are the most
vulnerable and if the cold doesn't get
them another enemy
might
[Music]
winter is a wolf's
Ally a time to feed off the suffering of
others
these are the biggest wolves in the
world and at 25 strong they're one of
the largest
packs size
matters when you
Giants 10 times heavier and well
armed the bison are
stronger as long as they stand their
ground but wolves create
panic
running for the woods is a
mistake trees break their
formation and expose the weak
alone a youngster is an easy
[Music]
target
but a mother will risk her own life to
save her
car they must make it back to the safety
of the
herd but deep snow saps the bison's
energy
again the Cal is
[Music]
isolated again it's
rescued now there's
hope
as long as the Cal can stay hidden
within the
[Music]
ranks
while the snow Remains the Bison gets
steadily
weaker
but on the grasslands change is
inevitable and often
[Music]
extreme by April it's 100° warmer than
at the start of the
year and a new danger is
brewing spring and and the start of
storm
season North America's Great Plains are
a hot spot for some of the most intense
thunderstorms on
Earth some mutate into
[Music]
supercells monsters with the equivalent
energy of 100 nuclear
bombs storms are becoming more frequent
here
and in grasslands across the
globe weather patterns are increasingly
erratic here the rains are a month early
and hitting
hard oh let the years worth of rain
in just a couple of
months enough to transform the
grasslands beyond
recognition the worst flly
in 50
[Applause]
years 4 ft of
water not a problem for the adults and
plenty of fresh
grass but a bit deep for a
calf
luckily he has a
snorkel these floods May complicate
things a little in the short
term but they'll Revitalize life on the
[Music]
Savannah as the flood waters
subside they reveal a flush of new
growth
and fuel a baby
boom but this can be a dangerous place
to take your first
steps
it's home to more large
Predators than anywhere else on
[Music]
Earth many Thompson gazelle THS won't
survive their first first
[Music]
hour their only hope is to
hide mothers clean their newborns to
remove any
scent but for this for there isn't
time
if Mom stands guard she'll blow its
cover she has no option but to walk
[Music]
away
the cheater's hunting instinct is
triggered by
movement a motionless fa looks
remarkably like a mound of
Earth
all it can do is stay
down stay
still hope someone else is spotted
[Music]
first
cheaters are
patient but the th will need to suckle
soon worse still the birth fluid is
attracting
flies
[Music]
e
he
a
distraction and a narrow
Escape
a waterbuck
[Music]
calf one Thor's fate is another's
Fortune surviving its first 24 hours is
the greatest challenge the for will face
[Music]
those that make it can enjoy growing up
on one of the most productive places on
the
planet North America's grasslands
support 3 million
Caribou they Journey up to 3,000 m a
year the longest land migration on
Earth but on most of the continent Mega
herds are a thing of the past
60 million bison once thundered across
these
Plains hunting decimated numbers to just
over 1,000
animals and bison are still rare
today
Midsummer time to fatten up before next
winter but that's getting
harder temperatures here have risen
three times more than the global
average and it's c creating plagues of
biting
flies each bison loses as much as a pint
of blood every
day and just when the Bulls need to be
at their
strongest to compete for mating
rights
the winner will sire up to 34s of next
year's
[Music]
carvs as a young B and
scrap an old bull watches
on waiting for the perfect moment to
enter the
arena it's Mating
Season an old bull w waits for a worthy
Challenger to
emerge
fresh to the fight the old bull enters
the
[Music]
ring the youngster is
stronger but the old bull is more
experienced targeting the flanks he
gains the upper
[Music]
hand
the young rival
Retreats mating rights
secured the old bull can enjoy the good
times but they won't last long
the dry season
begins from now on life just gets
tougher grass becomes less neutal
nutritious and elephants struggle to
satisfy their huge
appetites like so many grassland animals
their only option is to keep
[Music]
moving
elephants can walk over a 100 miles a
day in their search for
food and it can lead them into dangerous
territory these Lions special Iz in
bringing down large
prey still it's risky so they target the
most
vulnerable older Cals should be
[Music]
safe
but bravado can be a dangerous
thing
[Music]
there's nothing they can do but move
on
[Music]
as the sun robs the land of its
water the dry season
intensifies and Rain becomes a distant
mem
hippos suffer more than
most he spent the night
grazing but now the climbing sun is a
threat hippos can quickly overheat
he needs deep water and
fast there is one
pool but it's
occupied each bull hippo normally
commands a territory of 200
[Applause]
ft now 800 of Africa's most bad-tempered
animals are cramped
together and as humans take more water
for
irrigation there's less room than ever
before
somehow he's got to find a way
in his life depends on
[Music]
it
Out of Water this hippo would soon
overheat but the water hole is already
full it may not look very
inviting ox peckers ravage cracks in
their delicate
skin and 20 tons of waste a day has
turned it into a
cesspit but this hell
hole could save his
life if he's allowed
in
this resident bull is
bigger but the outsider is des
desate five tons of Hippo
Clash testing
bulk bite
size
and Brute
[Music]
Force The Outsider accepts
defeat he must Venture into the
unknown as the strangle hold of
drought
Titans the Earth is parched
and the
grass tender
dry fires can sweep across the plains at
40 m an
hour and reach temperatures of
800°
across Africa an area the size of half
the United States Burns every
year and with a warming climate
wildfires are set to spread even further
some capitalize on the
chaos rollers and be eaters pick off
fleeing
insects
known as The Undertaker bird marabu
stalks clean up
afterwards there's nothing left here for
the
grais
but the grass itself clings
on its Deep Roots Untouched by the
Flames all it needs now
is
water hammer Dr baboons wait months for
the rains to
arrive
but Earth this
dry needs more than a
shower this is one of the most drought
prone countries in the
world and it's getting
worse as our climate
changes water shortage is a sparking
Conflict for animals and humans alike
one of the only water holes for
miles it provides enough water for this
band of baboons to survive the dry
[Music]
season they're relatively strong in
health and
numbers further out on the Arid Plains
another band is
[Music]
thirsty
with little to drink out here they're
forced to the same Waterhole below the
cliff but when two bands meet it nearly
always ends in
violence females and babies are most at
risk
[Music]
if the outsiders want to
drink they'll have to
[Music]
fight one water
hole two bands of the
Boos The Outsiders need to
drink but the band at the water hole is
stronger this is how Wars
begin
the best survival strategy here is to
form super
bands bigger than the opposition
a
The Outsiders are forced to
retreat but not fast
enough these baboons use battles to
steal females from each
other
the winners expand to their
ranks while The Outsiders grow even
weaker
all they can do is buy their
time and try
again as a drought reaches its Peak
famine becomes a harsh
reality just a few months
old born at the wrong
time
mom couldn't produce enough
[Music]
milk she regurgitates precious
water desperately trying to cool down
and save
[Music]
herself then says her final
goodbye even at the best of times Sur
surviving on the planet's grasslands is
no walk in the
park and as the dry seasons become even
more extreme and
unpredictable Only the strongest will
have what it takes to make it
[Music]
through
adaptability unfailing
resolve
and the hope that eventually better days
will
[Music]
return 6 months older and born just
before the wet season this calf had a
stronger
[Music]
start the matriarch has seen hard times
before
she knows how to lead her family
[Music]
through enough water to go round until
the rains
return
[Music]
surviving on the
grasslands has never been
harder yet young and
old this herd is still standing
strong and hopefully will be for
generations to
[Music]
come